but you recently posted a vintage video  of you though from public school and I  wanted to take a look at this with y'all  go ahead my buddy sent that to me who  was in that my buddy Eddie honest we  grew up together that was either we  couldn't figure it out it was either  like 7th 8th or 9th grade we were in  middle school we thought we were flying  back in the day 3000 talent show we  ended up doing buddy do you remember any  of those men oh my god  I do  [Applause]  [Applause]  I will not stop talking until you  subscribe to my YouTube channel that's  right and I could talk a lot seriously  not gonna stop yep still here not going  anywhere I see you don't walk away from  this